macht irgendwie keine euro gibt's ja gar
nicht ja heute was ein schöner anfangen
und damit herzlich willkommen zu meiner
bereits im letzten video angekündigten
gut tue und zwar habe ich ungefähr vor
einem jahr mal den mumm für gemacht und
unsere alten wohnung und wir damals noch
gelebt haben wir sind ja ungefähr von
einem halben jahr umgezogen und mein
zimmer hier
das ist eigentlich echt cool es war
allerdings immer so dass ich mich zu 100
prozent gefallen hat das bag hat mir zum
beispiel nicht gefallen generell die
aufteilung keine ahnung irgendwie fehlt
also ein bisschen was und jetzt letzte
woche habe ich einmal einen ganzen tag
danach investiert das zimmerleute zu
gestalten aber auch ein bisschen geld in
die hand genommen und jetzt bin ich
eigentlich zufrieden wichtig ist zu
sagen das ist jetzt nicht so ein tool
wie ihr vielleicht erwartet so boah voll
krass geholt um youtuber und so also es
geht heute eigentlich nur mein zimmer
ich wollte es euch ein bisschen zeiten
wie ich das so eingerichtet habe und was
ich so wofür brauche und ich habe
eigentlich alles was ich brauche und
mehr braucht zum beispiel brauche ich
auch keine schranktüren viel spaß das
finde ich eigentlich ganz gut dass der
schrank offen ist ich glaube damit
könnten wir auch eigentlich anfangen
übrigens hoffe ich dass ihr bock auf der
rundtour fahre ich ja auch bock hat dass
irgendwann die ganze wohnung zeigen wenn
wir die richtig fertig haben weil dies
aber nicht so ganz fertig das wohnzimmer
könnte ich euch zu zeigen dass es auch
echt schön wir haben eine sehr schöne
wohnung ärgert hat aber da fehlt auf
jeden fall noch eine neues cooles sofa
oder entfernt werden wir keinen
fernsehens macht deswegen das jetzt noch
nicht also wir fangen einfach mal an
hier mit meinem schrank und zwar hier
oben einmal meine moody's eingeräumt das
lustige ist eigentlich immer ich habe so
die hälfte von meinen police bei meinen
eltern zu hause und die andere hälfte
hier und mich fragte mal richtig ab wenn
ich irgendein anziehen will der aber
nicht hier ist hier sind t-shirts da
sind nicht mehr viele von übrig hier
sind hosen die habe ich noch schuhe auch
die jesus da hab ich noch ein paar von
eigentlich keine ahnung wo das gott ist
und dass hier sind einfach ein paar
meiner jacken hier die jacke feiere ich
ziemlich die auch die finde ich auch
ganz cool die auch eigentlich sind die
alle ganz okay die winterjacken habe
schon ausgeräumt also die sind hier
nicht mehr drin
von der ganzen wohnung haben wollt dann
lasst noch nach oben da hab ich eben
glaub ich vergessen zu sagen
[Musik]
obendrauf noch ein paar kartons und hier
neben habe ich so eine wäsche geschenkt
bekommen da kann ich eigentlich immer
alle wäsche reinschmeißen die dreckig
ist und das hier ist mein handgepäck
stofer wenn ich irgendwo hinfliegen muss
nämlich immer den kann ich hier mal
kostenlos mitten im eigentlich der ist
cool so viel zum schrank dann geht man
hier weiter und zwar ist hier einmal das
bett da sah ich auch noch was zu und
hier habe ich jetzt mal nen fernseher
hingestellt solle kommode oder wie man
das dann habe ich schon eine längere
zeit gesucht bis ich jetzt die gefunden
habe ich finde ich echt cool
die ist in so schönen ja ich weiß nich
da kann man so schön alltag das hat mich
so ab
das ist zwei tage hier und schöne staub
draufkommt dass er auf jeden fall
brauche ich so aus weil ich es einfach
besser findet wenn der fernseher gut
drauf steht anstatt dass der hier an der
wand hängt und damit ich einfach noch
sachen verstauen kann zwar steht hier
einmal der fernseher ist meine ps hier
drin
dann habe ich diese coole aufladestation
in diesem fach sind einige meiner ordner
und fc köln schon irgendwas was ich für
die uni branche bleibe war und in diesem
fach habe ich mir einfach mal so ein
kleines kamera equipment fach gemacht
habe ich alle möglichen akkus drin alles
was ich so hier in köln eigentlich habe
dann auch ein objektiv hier ist eine
drohne drin
und hier oben nicht gerade noch mal eine
andere kamera drauf mit der ich die
normalen videos machen ist eigentlich
ganz gut weil hier habe ich dann immer
die kabel halt einmal für die canon
einmal für die sony kamera dann kann ich
die sofort drin aufladen und das nimmt
kaum platz weg
[Musik]
und das ist halt einfach kein kabelsalat
so dann haben wir hier im spiegel finde
ich immer ganz cool so was in barmstedt
das ding eigentlich rungen eigentlich
steht zwar anders aber ich find's cool
spiegel im zimmer zu haben kann man mal
schauen passt das was ich heute anhabe
oder passt ist eher weniger es ist so
also hier der spiegel so sieht das ganze
aus ja also das ist ja so diese ecke
hier mein zimmer hat glaube ich 18
quadratmeter also sieht jetzt nichts
besonders groß ist aber es ist völlig
okay und reicht aus hier haben wir zwei
große fenster an den seiten ist
eigentlich ganz cool hier
wir sind ziemlich viele wohnungen
übereinander und das ganze genau so ein
bisschen nach heraus ist alles echt
modern und die nachbarn sind auch alle
sendet also hier macht echt spaß zu
boden dann würde ich einfach mal sagen
wir kommen jetzt zum bett und das bett
steht einfach da ich wollte auf jeden
fall in die ecke haben einfach weil ich
irgendwie am schönsten der ecke findet
vor allem wenn dann morgens die sonne
aufgeht ist das eigentlich ganz schön
die rollladen kann ich ja wir sind
einfach zu machen und zur hälfte auf
machen das eigentlich auch ganz gut und
dieses bett habe ich vor gestern oder
vorgestern gekauft wir waren wirklich
sehr sehr wichtig wundert euch nicht
hier ist noch kein bettbezug drauf den
habe ich vergessen
die haben wir da so ein komplett paket
zusammengestellt und ich wollte wirklich
ein möglichst großes bett haben dieses
bild ist jetzt 81 x 2 meter 10 ist ein
boxspringbetten kann ich euch auch was
zu erzählen und zwar habe ich mich lange
darüber informiert welches
boxspringbetten ich jetzt lebe weil ich
finde boxspringbetten am bequemsten und
lasst euch da nicht veräppeln weil es
gibt auch vieles so viel 4 500 euro das
ist allerdings meistens nichts
[Musik]
also rückwärtssalto traue ich mir glaube
ich nicht oder machte mal dafür ist die
decke zu tief erreicht sportgeräte sowie
soviel zum bett das ganze ist auch
ziemlich hoch gefällt mir sehr gut
dazwischen dann auch sogleich ja so ein
kleines nachttischchen und dann kommen
wir jetzt zu meiner ecke wo ich
eigentlich immer schneider und zwar
sieht das ganze so aus ja das ist der
schreibtisch hier habe ich einmal mein
macbook stehen das ganze benutze ich
jetzt eigentlich nur noch für die uni
weil ich mir dann ein werk geholt habe
zum schneiden das ding ist halt ich
schreibt wirklich ausschließlich zu
hause und ich brauchte dein ding was
wirklich power hat und da habe ich mir
jetzt einfach mal diesen anhänger gönnt
sieht echt schön aus ist auch ziemlich
groß das ding halt ich weiß garnicht 27
zoll glaube ich und ich habe diesen
schreibtisch so ein bisschen über ecke
stellt einfach damit nicht zu viel platz
wegnimmt und habe ich noch so ein paar
einzelne fächer da habe ich auch noch
ein bisschen kamera equipment ohne
computer equipment drin
[Musik]
hier habe ich noch so ein bild hängen
das habe ich zum achtzehnten geburtstag
bekommen da hängt auch noch das bild was
früher in meinen videos hängen und wenn
man sich das ganze so relativ mittig
anschaut sieht das ungefähr so aus sie
haben wir den schrank den fernseher
da die beiden fenster da das bett und
hier meine arbeitsecke ich habe
natürlich auch noch einige zwischen
aufnahmen gemacht und das ganze noch ein
bisschen cooler gar zu stellen habt ihr
wahrscheinlich gesehen ansonsten wäre
das mein zimmer es ist jetzt kein großes
zimmer habe ich ja schon gesagt aber ich
finde also ich fühle mich wirklich wohl
wir kann man sich auf jeden fall sehr
gut aushalten ach so ganz kurz wach und
zwar kam letztens marsch von hier aus
das ganze jahr auf 150 stück limitiert
und das problem ist wir haben leider nur
100 verschicken können
das haben jetzt irgendwie 1920 leute ihr
geld zurückbekommen also wundert euch
bitte nicht wenn ihr euer geld deswegen
halt zurück bekommen habt es tut mir
auch super light aber sonst hätte die
jetzt vier wochen warten müssen wir
wollten nicht dass ich da jetzt leute
beschweren dass ihr euch deswegen
beschwert und vier wochen warten ist
eine lange zeit deswegen habe ich gesagt
gut dann erstatten wir den einfach das
geld zurück ich hoffe dass wieder hat
euch gefallen wie gesagt wenn ihr
vorkommt auch der kultur von der ganzen
wohnung wenn die fertig ist last auf
jeden fall mit fetten daumen nach oben
da dann würde ich sagen checks netz
schon installiert wir sind uns
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder morgen
gibt's neues video jetzt kommen wieder
öfter videos habe ich die letzten male
auch schon immer gesagt dass dann aber
irgendwie nie gemacht aber jetzt geht es
wieder los versprochen ach so und das
jetzt noch mal ein schreibtisch stuhl
dann habe ich auch schon ewig hier oben
habe ich meinen kaputten play button
aufgehangen wir haben jetzt also noch da
ziemlich viel platz an dieser wand und
wir haben über dem fernseher auch noch
eine menge platz und da ist auch noch
platz und da ist auch eigentlich ist
überall noch platz dafür und zwar ist
das vielleicht ist eine kleine
aufforderung an euch wenn ihr die idee
habt ihr was dennoch so hier an die
wände kann dann schreibt das gerne in
die kommentare lassen sich das wissen
würde mich sehr interessieren
und ja wenn ich mal gespannt was euch so
einfällt so viel dazu tun und wir sehen
uns vertreiben und ist jetzt die mit
heruntergefallen und die lampe habe ich
euch auch noch vergessen zu erwähnen das
ist eine tolomeo lampe ist eine
qualitäts lampe also wie kann wirklich
einiges die leuchtet und das war es dann
auch wieder
das war es mit dem video hat